something's in the air right now
like i'm losing track of time billy
eilish
just dropped her new track lost cause
and the accompanying self-directed music
video
now kim kardashian is showing love for
the grammy winner
and it's a real women supporting women
vibe
really really cool on wednesday the 19
year old singer released the song off
her upcoming sophomore album happier
than ever you weren't even there
that day i was waiting on you
i mean who else wants to live in this
music video
[Music]
it's like a girls night done right
twister
junk food silly string a dance party
dancing on
counters laugh attacks and coordinating
outfits
and speaking of those coordinating
outfits if some of it looks familiar
it's because the ladies are rocking some
items from kim kardashian's skins
i love that shortly before the music
video dropped
kim hit up her insta story sharing this
teaser clip
writing i spy skims and she added what
we're all thinking
billy eilish lost cause video fire
which is so incredible and it was so
amazing as for billy
she reposted kim's post to her own story
with a heart-faced emoji
it's like so flattering of course billy
recently traded her signature baggy
clothes and green roots for a whole new
look
i mean i just think it's like if it's
something you
you feel just like do that back
in may she appeared on the cover of
vogue going all
out old hollywood glam complete with
corsets and
honey blonde locks at the time she
shared a few snaps from her shoot on
instagram alongside the caption quote
i love these pictures and i loved doing
the shoot
do whatever you want whenever you want
[ __ ] everything else
gotta give it to him oh and get this
that post
surpassed 1 million likes in just six
minutes
making it the fastest pick to ever
achieve that feat on the platform
i'm just happy about it but fashion has
always been important to the oceanized
singer
back in 2019 she opened up to e.t about
her unique style that's always making
waves
i like to be judged so i want to i want
to see heads look up
it's really sick it's kind of exactly
what i want people to care about you
know
the things that the people sort of know
me for are all the things i want to be
known for if that makes sense because
style has always been something i care
[Music]
about